free at last free at last thank god
almighty we are free at last
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
are you miss tubman the name's harry
well thank god in heaven for the work
that you're doing harriet
before you thank me
let me tell you
i've led hundreds of slaves to freedom
through this here underground railroad
but it ain't gonna be easy
are you ready
all right
then hike up your britches
and follow me
to freedom
[Music]
[Music]
watch this black molasses
[Music]
but where is she now
that was an easy part now stay close
this next 500 miles gets a little sticky
[Music]
forget this man i'm going back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
free at last free at last thank god
almighty we are free at last
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
next speaker the reverend robert jones
[Applause]
how am i supposed to follow that
i can't nobody can follow that
oh
all right
good afternoon um
that is the the best speech i've ever
heard in my entire life
ever
i have never heard a better speech
and now it is my turn to speak
huh
we put this running order together right
you know um dr king
he actually covered a lot a lot of what
i was going to say um you know my speech
is uh uh you're gonna find this funny
y'all my speech was actually called uh a
vision for the future
i'm not saying that dr king copied my
speech i'm
no no no
i'm saying i'm not saying that i'm not
saying he tried to copy it watch out
listen to what i'm
wow you know what no come on i'm just
saying i'm just saying i'm just saying
it's a joke did i not say it like a
joke okay
nope
apparently i have six more minutes let's
see a red red hills of georgia he
got that out there
okay you know what all right here's
something here's something new here's
something uh brand new how ab okay this
is off me talking off the top of my head
here everybody uh wha why how about if
we let uh black people enslave white
people for okay you know that sounded a
lot better in my head before i said it
so that's uh
that wouldn't work
is it warm
is anybody else warm
whoa
okay okay okay here's what we're gonna
do here's what we're gonna do all right
dr king talked about um uh all the races
coming together right right so what i
want every negro to do here today is
find the nearest white person and give
him a hug just just give him a hug okay
nope sir you're not being attacked
you're not being attacked you're being
hugged okay everybody take it easy here
okay everybody relax you know what we
don't need ten negroes hugging one white
person okay let's just let's yo that's
the new rule not ten on one one on one
we just take turns and everything okay
so everybody relax okay oh my goodness
sir she doesn't need to be defended she
doesn't need to be fetish she's okay
she's okay okay all right so man okay
opposite is that necessary i don't think
you're necessarily officer no man please
please take it easy sir we everybody
take it
ladies and gentlemen
please turn off your cell phones and
enjoy our production
of lunch with greatness
my my my what a beautiful day in
montgomery alabama
i swear the sun is so hot i nearly
melted indeed dr king but i suspect we
didn't meet here to talk about the
weather
indeed brother malcolm
unless of course
we articulate that
the sun in this country shines brighter
on some than it does on others
yes but when the sun does shine on us it
is growing the seeds of revolution
i see your point brother malcolm but
do not those same seeds need to be
watered
with love
well i suppose that is the subject of
some discussion dr king
and i am all for discussion brother
malcolm
unless of course the words devolve into
proclamations of hate
well is that not
why we are here today dr king
to discuss
yes brother malcolm
and i am confident that as we discuss we
are going to discuss it
and discuss it
until
i say
that
our people have never resorted to
violence before the white man gave them
no choice but to pay him back in the
only currency he understands
brother malcolm
is that what you really have to say
at this point
in our lunch
indeed dr king because we didn't land on
plymouth rock
plymouth rock landed on us
[Applause]
okay well yes all right yeah i've heard
you say that before i
don't know why we're talking about rocks
when in fact it is the flesh and the
bone and the the dreams i have a dream
that someday our children will be judged
by the content of their character not by
the color of their skin
same for me same for me in fact i
believe that one day a black man will
become the president of the united
states of america
hopefully for eight years
obama
it is of course 2020 is that's a given
right
that's a given you know i mean but in
order to get there isn't he going to
need the help of our strong beautiful
black women
gotta respect the sisters
gotta respect the systems
[Applause]
and that's what we're here to say is
that we are the new black panther party
what's the biggest problem facing the
movement
well you know we're supposed to be in
this era of so-called post-racial
harmony with all people in america but
us blacks are being murdered all over
the place and we get the same treatment
time and time again we're not even
second-class citizens we third class
stand up black america and declare the
white america that we aren't going to
take this no more okay why come out now
and say this you know what you have 400
years to get it right america but you
don't know how to treat your people all
people it's time to stand up it's time
to take back it's time for us to fight
back and we don't take your phony words
anymore we're not going to do it we want
concrete results you know you you hear
what we're saying to you united snakes
of america
what are you supposed to do when the
whole world is watching and no one is
saying anything we will not be silent
okay you sir anything you wanted to say
oh me no i'm good
[Music]